would you switch your size with your
foot size absolutely no doubt in my mind
they're nothing they're ten and a half
but yeah I mean that's a yeah
but you gotta walk around but then you
got yeah so then I got a little feet you
switch sides Oh I thought you just met
what do you want you're like oh no so
now you're walking with like probably a
size like six shoe okay I mean it is
comical people would always be like
what's up with your little baby food but
and then
would it be so
beautiful if you're like oh you got
little feet I know what you and then you
just pull out this hammer and people
were like what the man you got a
ten and a half inch